[Musique]
merci bâti en valeur fatima qui va nous
rentrer regarder blanche neige sinon on
est à fond dans blanche neige les chéris
alors c'est la scène du baiser qui pose
problème à fatima
plus globalement en fait la preuve que
les féministes ont avec les comptes ce
qui nous vient le faux pas comprendre
que les comptes ils ont un rôle là on
est entre adultes dans ce plateau les
comptes en effet lire on les fait voir
un dessin animé à nos enfants à trois
quatre cinq six ans et il faut bien
comprendre que c'est l'âge où on
saint-prime ont fait l'apprentissage des
côtes de la société les comptes n'ont
pas du tout été pensés comme des
divertissements
c'était des leçons assortie d'une
moralité et d'ailleurs les grands
conteurs qu'on connaît grimm perrault et
ses terrasses et on appelait ça des
moralistes et en fait tous les comptes
ont toujours été réécrit d'une époque à
l'autre selon les valeurs de l'époque
normalement oui alors c'est le baiser
qui pose problème parce que vous êtes en
train de dire c'est qu'on donne le
mauvais exemple aux enfants en fête
typiquement par exemple le chaperon
rouge vous devez tous connaître une deux
trois versions avec la faim qui
reflétait les valeurs de l'époque celle
du xviie siècle tout le monde mourait à
la fin il n'est pas très rigoriste un
baiser son consentement qu'on compose en
fait con con oui tu pose problème dans
blanche neige on sait que c'est un
charmant embrasse blanche neige sans son
consentement oui j'allais si tu es trop
ce qui nous choque souvent dans les
comptes en tout cas ce qui nous déplaît
est ce qu'on aimerait changer c'est il
ya plusieurs constantes la première
c'est qu'il faut se méfier de toutes les
lanes à chaque fois qu'on lit un compte
l'héroïne toutes ses ennemis ce sont les
femmes les belles-soeurs les marâtre la
sorcière elles vont être sauvés
uniquement par anna et puis il ya ces
passages là et moi ce qui m'enchante en
tant que féministe c'est que aujourd'hui
nécessaire ne serait-ce qu identifié
comme un problème moi je suis militant
depuis 12 ans ce n'est que depuis mitsou
que la question de d'embrasser ou
d'avoir des pratiques sexuelles par
ailleurs avec une personne quand cet
état d'inconscience est en train d'être
parlée et les filles mettre des mots
dessus c'est à dire que ce soit des
cadets filles qui se sont retrouvés dans
des soirées étudiantes quoi que ce soit
qui vont s'endormir bourré à 3 heures du
matin être réveillé par quelqu'un
qu'elles ne connaissent pas du fait de
pratiques sexuelles
c'était quelque chose qui était
extrêmement honteux et
même n'osais pas en parler parce que je
disais que ce n'était pas à elle d'aller
dormir dans une des chambres du meilleur
ami et sur la question du couple
quand les jeunes se mettent en couple
c'est très difficile de poser des
barrières et notamment pendant le sommet
où les état d'inconscience se faire
photographier en brasse est acquis
mobile à la blanche neige ou en découdre
et jean-edouard tenait voulant jeter
jeanne essence est morte à ce moment là
et le prince la ramène à l'aviron le
sort que reese s'est depuis mon enfance
et j'ai une petite fille qu à trois ans
en ce moment je lui montre peter pan
alors je sais pas quelle est pour vous
la symbolique de peter pan mais je
trouve ça complètement aberrant c'est
super agressif moi aucun moment j'ai vu
j'ai vu dans cette scène quelque chose
comme un viol comme un non consentement
j'y vois un compte en fait je pense que
ça passe surtout par l'éducation des
parents aussi bien aujourd'hui le film
en fait ils datent des années 30 au
moment où ça a été écrit à aucun moment
cela n'a été pensé comme un baiser force
et ça vient plus à l'est rien la plus
poétique que ça c'est un baiser
salvateur c'est un baiser qui lui permet
de retourner à la vie donc je pense
qu'il faut il faut pas voir du sexisme
baisers forcés par tous alors gilles
verdez qui sera jamais prince charmant
lui ça le diront je ne veux pas être
prince charmant parce qu'ils agressent
sexuellement blanche morts
notez comme telle elle ne dit pas oui
d'interdît n'ont rien et c'est ce que
dit la maman elle ne peut rien dire donc
elle n'est pas en état de dire oui nos
qu'il la laisse tranquille mais ça
n'allait pas du tout en colère blanche
bien joué j'ai rencontré vous à non mais
aujourd'hui je demande tout simplement
son interdiction a bloqué aujourd'hui
foutu lui envoie un mail avant il ya un
huissier pour constater si tu as le
droit ou pas le droit de prendre comment
ça se passe je vous entends mais sauf
que ce baiser là en fait blanche neige
vous estimez que les petites filles qui
regardent ce conte vont devenir l des
victimes
oui elles veulent il a interdit les
petits garçons qui vont garder vont
devenir des prédateurs danse annexée ça
a l'air très simple la question du
consentement et je conçois que ça a
l'air comme ça juridiquement très sabah
typiquement l'aca a débattu heures que
juridiquement il a raison mais mes
sentiments mes ongles à nous mais quoi
qu'il en veut pas du bord des berges à
tous le mot existe où la question du
consentement et des barrières qu'on se
pose dans le couple existe et puis moi
je voudrais juste vous faire à l'idée
chez en orbite de la reine mère la reine
elle veut elle veut tuer sa mère belge n
6 a été scénarisé comme c'est ça ne le
fait pas c'est pas plus grave que ce
baiser pâques nous sommes ans a été
scénarisé comme ça d'un prince qui l'a
fait la sérénade et c'est scénarisé
comme ça en choisit que les cons les
personnages féminins de sorcière berl à
la figure de la sorcière en train d'être
réhabilité parce qu'on est en train de
découvrir que les sorcières qui était
brûlée exhorté alors j'aime ma région
puis fréjus si je peux juste me
permettre là on est en train de parler
de quoi
première chose et comme je vous disais
les comptes ont toujours été réécrit et
réinterprété donc c'est normal qu'on est
dans une génération qui va vouloir
appliquer une nouvelle morale et
remettre en cause ce qui est mais sans à
face à ma version et d'art sûrs comme
l'or madame à l'origine
lille est faite de perroy que ces traces
sont pire que çà mais rien n'a été fait
je vous le donne en mille dans cent ans
et notre humanité survie on va étudier
retracer qu'en 2021 il ya eu une
révolution qui s'appelle itou à ce
moment là une nouvelle version est née
liés à cette moralité la deuxième chose
c'est que cette version elle ne
disparaîtra pas vous inquiétez pas elle
va être de plus en plus obsolète et
ringardise et parce que disney il a
quand même fait chanter à blanche-neige
qui fait le moment refusé le ménage pour
cette mecque en nettoyant la chambre
penser que le ballet est votre cher et
tendre le bâton
bonjour de toute manière ringardisait
avait la même chose qui est la dernière
il ya toujours une relecture de tours
gainsbourg quand il réécrit la
marseillaise il veut lui redonner un
sens politique en 2017 il ya les eaux
marchetto qui a refait le comte l'opéra
de carmen de bizet et il a voulu abolir
la fin on disant que ça ne correspondait
plus à ses valeurs qu'elle soit
aiguilles et parce qu'il s'est refusé à
un homme mais ça n'a pas ça n'a pas
aboli la version de briser l
le problème c'est que vous prenez ce
compte qui a été remanié et remanier et
remanier de façon extrêmement littérale
en le transposant comme s'il s'agissait
non pas d'une fiction il n'y même d'un
dessin animé mais d'un documentaire où
il nomme remettrait la serait celui qui
permettrait à une femme de s'émanciper
d'être heureuse de revenir à la vie etc
or moi je le prend pour ce qu'il est
c'est à dire un compte qui est en règle
générale lus par des parents lesquels
peuvent re que creux contextualiser
peuvent évidemment pas d'âne
pardonnez-moi mais peau d'âne pourquoi
personne ne s'insurge il s'agit d'un
père incestueux qui veut faire l'amour
avec nos réalités toujours là mais si
j'ai ouvert m
moi j'agis roman voyage hiraumont pas
toujours brillé ce qu'il dit est le fait
que le prince se met à genoux face à
blanche neige
est ce que si régressif pour l'homme de
se mettre à genoux même franchement je
vais même pas m'abaisser à ce genre de
davantage pense contestation date je ne
crois pas que embrasser quelqu'un quand
l'état d'âme du tout la même chose
et là je pense qu'on est en train de
jouer au con mais ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que moi par exemple même si
je suis consciente que c'est de la
fiction
il m'a fallu des décennies moi je ne
déteste parler pour les autres vous le
savez ça m'a fallu des décennies pour
bien intégrer que le mon destin n'allait
pas être marqué par le fait qu'à un
moment je vais être sauvé par un homme
par une rencontre
c'est quelque chose qu'on déconstruit
nuit parce que vous savez que vous avez
aujourd'hui une trentaine d'années les
petites filles qui le lisent aujourd'hui
elles sont dans une société où justement
elles voient leur mère est vite au
travail et voit la fumée ils ont pu
montrer nous attaquons maintenant je
suis d'accord je suis d'accord sur une
chose semble donc comme vous giljura
band swing ou alors je trouve que c'est
intéressant de effectivement de mettre
le doigt sur un problème de société et
d'expliquer aux enfants que c'est un
conte de fées qu effectivement dans ce
cas précis c'est un conte mais
qu'effectivement un baiser ça se demande
où cela pourrait programmer ses je
trouve ça pas inintéressant c'est la
première fois que je suis d'accord avec
eux à la traîne et voilà
mais en fait le prince charmant là il
lui grimpe pas dessus à la blanche neige
en finlande
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est clairement sexuelle est perçu et
clients sur plus de violence en fait il
n'y a pas besoin de se jeter sur quelle
cohérence ou deux mais agressé
violemment pour que ce soit quelque
chose qui dérange elles sont concentrées
là le prince et roja consentement avec
la plus grande des douceurs en fait
c'est pas l'inconnu du coin elle c'est
la princesse lui c'est le but voilà ces
deux âmes soeurs ils sont destinés
quelque part il lui fait un tout petit
bisou lui semble habiter visite de
l'amour qui la fait revivre parce que
c'est vrai qu'on est bien quand on est
amoureux quand on a l'amour dans sa vie
de soi et de l'autre d'ailleurs
et alors par signe de respect il
s'agenouille et il attend que sa
princesse serait d'ailleurs je vois pas
le jeu gère bien que ces castaldi ne
sera jamais blanche neige parce que même
si le coincement brasse avec sa bouille
il m'arrive de regarder non mais c'est
vrai que ça voilà voilà
oui à quand la wii à quatre pour son nom
à 96 points il ya des autrices par
exemple comme t'y fais une vie qui a
fait une oeuvre qui s'appelle compte à
rebours où elle revisite tous les
comptes en les rendant ses ministres en
changeant les rôles des méchants et des
gentils et ça leur donne une couleur et
ça fait partie de la liberté
d'expression aussi de revisiter les
contes sa n'abolira pas les anciens mais
ça remet au devant de la scène des
préoccupations qui moi m'en chante parce
que voir des petites gênes qui disent
que non ça c'est pas normal
et de s'insurger contre ça bah mon
boulot ta copie